John's in Virginia hey John welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show you very much merry
Christmas merry Christmas to you how can
I help
ah I am 61 years old and my wife is 16
she's retired on disability I'm still
working our household income is are my
faller $100,000 plus her social security
which is about $45,000 in per year and
I've just got a small credit card bill
on work on paying off it's only $2,000
or Janet paid off about a month or two
um we own two homes they're worth about
900,000 combined our mortgages 200,000
we all got 200,000 mortgage on one the
other ones paid off all right how come a
day uh the problem I have is I've got
too many toys I've got three kabak we've
got three cars and I can jetski and I've
got you cannot just you know I'm
wondering uh if I should go ahead and
pay off the could sell a couple of cars
just accept the fact that I lost money
on them you know I'm not gonna get back
what I put into them and just move on so
I can't get psychologically past the
thought that I you know I bought this
car for ten thousand two and a half
years ago when I can only sell for five
well that's what I was horrible for the
paid off - that's what they all do right
it is just I just I just you know I have
a the problem I had was I I like cars my
every couple years I buy an old one or
buy one item and pour money into the
repairs may end up having to pay the
credit card off and then you know I'll
spend like ten thousand for one and I'll
end up fixing you know doing some repair
work in up to 13 and then three years
later like I don't need this car but I
can't get past a psychological aspect of
both I sell it seven I've lost $6,000
yeah you know I guess well I think I
think the thing is you've got to decide
what you're buying a car for in the
future in the past is over
okay the decisions already been made you
bought a car it went down in value
selling it selling it just means you
admit it
uh-huh it's already already lost the
money but so
it just means you admit that you've lost
the money right yes so but then the next
time you get ready to do this you buy it
sounds like you like tinkering with them
well I don't do as much thing for his
idea I love driving it but I usually end
up having to have someone else do all
the work on them okay I need to buy the
car in such a way that the work that
you're going to do actually enhances the
value not just gets turns into lost
money because the lost money part of the
fix-up has not been bringing you real
joy right it has value to my life no no
but it Amon is you feel like you've I
gotta like you've got this regret in the
back in the you know in the back of your
tongue is bad taste in your mouth yeah
I'm sitting outside I look at the winner
right now but that more the cars again I
just saw yeah I should get rid of it it
but I just put new tires on it and add
new brakes from the past year and it's
like mm-hmm and I feel I had that
psychological you know thought well I
can't get rid just put all that money
into it yeah well you know you've again
you've lost the money selling it just
means you admitted it
so that's all that is and the question
is what do you want to drive and let's
do that at the least expensive way
possible and sometimes that means buying
a fixer-upper sometimes means up you
just buy a car and drive it but they all
go down in value pretty much rare
exception would be if you had classic
cars that you were doing as a hobby and
you really know what you're doing and
you're buying a bargain on a classic car
like you know I've got a 1960 Corvette
that's a frame-up restoration that one
actually goes up in value but the
Corvette sitting next to it that's new
goes down in value more so it's pretty
much offsets but yeah you just kind of
got to know what you're getting into and
go
I can accept this loss financially and
emotionally as part of what I'm doing
and that's pretty much true with all
cars that we have to do that and that's
why you want your cars to be a smaller
percentage of your overall income so we
tell you not to own things with motors
and wheels added together equaling more
than about half your annual income which
you've not violated that so there's
nothing in this discussion that goes but
are you crazy
there's none of that going on here you
just bought a thirteen thousand our car
went down in value to five over a few
years that's kind of like normal stuff
do that the thing you just want to ask
yourself when you're doing the repairs
are are these repairs I'm going to keep
it long enough to justify or do I need
to just sell the car like it is before I
do the repairs and that kind of stuff
but tires and brakes it's just part of
operating the car man